okay it's a boy psychobabble
and we're playing episode 2 of the final
season of The Walking Dead now let's do
this yeah that says we start is because
I accidentally played bed of it okay so
leave me alone okay I'm trying here yeah
yeah yeah okay
I don't [ __ ] late because the third
one is out I know who's that Clementine
for someplace we could call her thank
you brother but I'm 35 oh my god
ugly people they're hideous he wasn't
too cool like a chance at having a home
see this is I need socialism he had to
go back to the train station to see if
any food survived the explosion okay
okay say I shoved him into a pack of
walkers
I found marlin and Brody in the pipe 8
inches I haven't seen this on like 10
years like said hey why oh wait now cuz
he was like selling Marlin traded
Tennessee's older sister that sucked
them that's fine that's yeah I don't
need that [ __ ] disgusting
he attacked Brody and locked me in the
basement with her yeah well before
Marlon stole AJ's gun and tried to
convince them he basically did with
everyone against him the fight went out
of Marlon I told him he could stay but
he couldn't did the kid like [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] face yeah and AJ pulled the
trigger he remembered what I taught him
boys covert had to always aim for the
head yeah I remember that I was like
whoa baby
I can't s - s Mouse died or something
I mean I'm not [ __ ] dirty it's like
what day is that
[ __ ] you down making a [ __ ] fire
around sleeping coffee I didn't do it
the coffee is one thing I would not
drink at the Bachman because you found a
run out and you don't wanna get an
addicted to something that you like
can't get every day beam water that's
what coffee is water
yeah you tell them I heard Louis and
what he called me
am i a murderer uh yeah but maybe I
taught him it's a kadish I think aim for
the head what's called me a murderer but
we're supposed to kill bad stuff
monsters yeah it was a [ __ ] monster
that's what I'm saying that's what I was
saying
understand that you were justified I was
justified yep yep
you really [ __ ] it up that cat
his chicks nice actually turn that bench
[Music]
kids can shoot me of course yes [ __ ] off
Louis go [ __ ] yourself
yeah Louis your little [ __ ] go [ __ ]
yourself
your [ __ ] [ __ ] your dumb your dreads
are done yeah seriously
let's go sorry
yeah I'm not scary I wasn't I didn't act
like a monster I know you're not we just
need to prove it to them get back Mitch
get back
sym really the last person who pointed a
weapon at me is dead that's right [ __ ]
you want to join him we got to be tough
yeah we got to be tough that's all I
gotta say we got to be tough okay
rosacea what is it you know it is baby
killed a lot of people no did you kill
your friend Lee because he was a monster
yes what are you talking about it was
probably because he murdered of the
other guy that's a horrible thing to say
to a kid that was gonna [ __ ] shoot me
things I didn't want that for him he
deserved better
yes dad hey general remember that I'll
be this go away from me
oh yeah I took [ __ ] judgment day
isn't it yeah I can spit on this Drive I
wonder why
seems right though I brought you
something an egg sir what happened - I
don't wanna say anything out of line but
better not say exactly smart guy is
[Music]
always right so dad I guess I hope
they'd see them from now okay
can we play with them later sure maybe
started
this is gonna suck they're gonna say a
lot of things about Marlon and Bernie
some true some not here's a dick just
get through it without upsetting
everybody okay
he was a dick I'll try time they get
that [ __ ] hey coffee [ __ ] check all
this that's good that's good
the [ __ ] that's it I find it yeah hey AJ
where's that toy Tim just gave you let's
show it off with the rest of our stuff
yeah it's get some swag up the ass
I like all those stuff it's tiny but
it's okay you know to [ __ ] out of here
right
should I get this that funny that take
pills huh
ready yeah brah let's do this as [ __ ]
okay
yeah
got God
attend the fun are all okay
I did yes come on
yeah we ready to spit on this [ __ ]
grave
you got a stick you got to stick through
your own hands
get the [ __ ] out of that dock okay he's
cute actually I can't have a know he's
in there you know yes oh god they're
here so what they knew Brody didn't they
what why do people have funerals max is
the same one let's goodbye goodbye to
someone you've lost but their day I know
it's confusing this is your last chance
to see them it's kind of like they're
playing pretend pretend and Marlon
didn't do all the bad stuff he did yeah
let's just get through this people do
some animals too even monsters
I think of it as Brody's funeral not
Marlins because they're talking about
both of them 10 you ready
I'm ready to dance to dance brother you
always said you wanted to go to the
beach [ __ ] I can't not for Marlon after
what he did to the twins and Brody you
didn't even like Brody
I can't someone else do that [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] dude
don't seriously he was your best friend
wasn't perfect but he deserved better
than to get gunned down by a kid they
just killed him like it was nothing
dessert after what he did to Brody
Marlon deserved exactly what he got yeah
yeah I I was justified mm-hmm Clem told
me yeah [ __ ] I can't listen to this
damn that's [ __ ] that's what you told
him that what he did was was we can't
wait we should talk this out what I know
this sucks I'm sorry for that
I really am but AJ did what he had to do
what you're [ __ ] me right now see
what I mean how can any of us trust
these [ __ ] people what are you saying
I'm saying they got a [ __ ] go take a
vote majority decides they stay or they
leave today go [ __ ] yourself that does
seem fair are you serious okay get out
[ __ ] you can't just kick us out we
brought you here that means we can get
rid of you too that is [ __ ] up after
all Marlon did who wrongs don't make a
right
votes the only way to settle this Oh
we'll be arguing forever
fine I guess we're [ __ ] voting
Louis needs to vote could you go get him
and try to talk to him leave my land hey
could you guys go wait in the dorm I'll
come get you
please don't kick us out come on let's
go
I really like the ambience right here I
like the crickets okay I guess while
this Lots out sick I'm gonna kind of
lift legs are out of the main Sam that's
girl so you have to see that Oh light
that light out
okay oh my god I say oh my god I think I
think the reason there's no sound here
what do ever is that I can't stand music
when in games and [ __ ] like that so I
just [ __ ] eat it but it really makes
for [ __ ] awkward ah scenes like this
where there's nothing like they don't
leave it there's no there's no talking
okay so yeah Jesse can I hear my voice
you know I'm just gonna hear my advice
yeah that virtual real I don't know that
your auntie I can't I can't tell
mm-hmm okay noise again noise again is
that nice I'm playing [ __ ] basketball
did you want to stay here near Macon
sooner than die [ __ ] kicking us out
AJ stop you pick your toe or something
what is the [ __ ] are you doing come here
sit down
no so I'm gonna kick that thing out yeah
that's how it is remember what we do
it's still really really bad I know this
can't [ __ ] take it
you are a dumb I should [ __ ] miss
that one sorry I guess they didn't
listen I'll try not to be mad but I
don't know if I can we stop we think and
we feel better you're still mad huh yeah
and uh I think I'm sad too
I did what you told me to I know you're
a good listener Annika Sean I was right
it didn't work
why'd you tell me to do that if it did
it's my fault it's your fault I like the
other kids I got it
Sam that's all right Louis he's annoying
he had a go all right hey was this patch
yeah yeah hello this is so dumb
get outta here those you have to leave
Louis don't we get to vote I vote that
we stay that's not how it works
maybe it should be you don't have to
like it
you're a second Chris I don't fine I get
it we'll learn to live with your
decisions somehow finally you know this
is [ __ ] wrong you're not gonna fight
it at all what's the point you've
already decided yes we have Lois you're
the worst if we voted fairly it's
[ __ ] and you'd know it if you
weren't so used to burying your head in
the sand
oh I'm burying my head in the sand hey
Marlon all you want but you can't tell
me Ajay's and dangerous too
it is actually [ __ ] too interesting
[ __ ] okay yes I'll wait for you to pack
up then Lois and I'll escort you out
pass is safe so we could have happily
dumped you outside the gates thanks for
making sure that we get him under
control
AJ breathe
hey the second looseness got downrod
where's Tim I gotta say goodbye he was
really upset about the vote he's not
talking to anybody that's my boy ten
it's kind of sad yeah wait does AJ still
have that gun death [ __ ] you Chris he
does [ __ ] that go [ __ ] yourself tape
that guy's it's yours
AJ you should keep it loose you're
kicking us out they're gonna take the
gun go [ __ ] yourself I thought you were
only gonna use it on monsters I wouldn't
be so worried about it five let the kid
keep the murder weapon
that's right slow walk out of there
sister
yeah it's [ __ ] nuts out there
I gotta tell you the senior is amazing
in this game let's take a [ __ ] Kia or
something again it's not so bad
I mean you've done this before probably
don't pretend you care bad guys pretend
you give a [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] idiot Louis
I can hate that [ __ ] he's almost like
tear down we're here anything you wanna
say before we go
I've said plenty thanks for trying to
keep us you're welcome I wish you could
stay I don't want this don't kick us out
if you really feel that way take us back
don't let them kick us out I can't Clem
half of them are convinced you're as bad
as Marlon or worse if you came back
someone else might get hurt I I can't
risk it I'm sorry
this is [ __ ]
still got that gun yeah just try to be
more careful with it okay I will
Lois get the [ __ ] out of here
let's get going
the Sun will set soon how do you know I
[ __ ] know I don't know I can just reel
[Music]
back to the beginning the [ __ ] [ __ ]
shitty at me
come on out I saw a couple of you on the
road how long do you think you can hide
[ __ ] that's the man from the train
station yes
I thought he dies you can survive a bite
if you cut it off fast enough Oh stay
here
yeah [ __ ] up shift was e okay what the
[ __ ] kind of have an agent is that this
count you finish him off
shoot that [ __ ] shucks and shoot him
any closer your friend might good to see
you holy [ __ ]
we're looking for a kid runs a community
near here Marlon he's dead [ __ ] this can
still work how about it you want to take
us back to your school help us talk to
you yes it's not like you have many
other options they'll kill me and him
and probably both of you she's lying
please sure if you do like we asked
otherwise I'm happy to crack his head
the [ __ ]
you ever seen that's pretty specific
that's just how it'll look
I'm in time
hi my name is Lily I've never seen you
before when this all started a man named
Li saved you or stole you I was never
sure until what
wait you're the first that [ __ ] like
shot someone in the head [ __ ] is this I
said
Lee isn't with you I don't blame him
yeah you shut that [ __ ] in the face
that was insane
Lee should have left you behind - oh
that's not cool
listen to you if you repeat his mistakes
your little boy there you may be able to
keep this up a while longer but
eventually he'll slow you down he can
handle himself a bullet you couldn't
dodge a desperate cry for help that
brings the herd I don't think so
AJ knows how it handled himself he's got
spirit I'll give you that but you and I
know that won't be enough we'll take you
back to the Delta to join our people we
have walls we have working solar panels
and we grow our own food
all we need from you is to go back to
your friends and convince them to come
peacefully no one will be harmed
I'm not Marlon here's what I'll do that
way I'm sure you'll play nice
be smart about this Clementine it's an
us or them kind of world clown if you
want to save your little one she's
[ __ ] now [ __ ] worst I hate that
[ __ ] I'm glad I got shot I got a press
ear or something I bet right now what's
it the painting left or right or E or
shift which one I left
oh my god um down or up I think down no
how cute what the [ __ ] took [ __ ] mio
speaking teachers typing
that guy only has one arm there's half
hey best bet but at the same time that
lady's a terrible [ __ ] stop she's so
bad I'm also like insanely athletic oh I
got in here bats I pressed the right
button
I know I'm fooling around like clumsy
Kevin okay sir
sir I already voted leave me alone
step it [ __ ] [ __ ]
till you want me to kill you you're so
young oh sorry
zombies
[Music]
I can't I why Betts is here here's the
next dance person I guess is present
okay okay
second disgusting and these [ __ ] know
I got
[ __ ] run [ __ ] run run [ __ ] run
holy [ __ ] that's [ __ ] disgusting
not [ __ ] more no we'd better get the
[ __ ] out of here [ __ ] no wait
that's disgusting get out of my face
they're all so slow why don't you just
like kind of like heat away we need to
run you just kind of walk
okay hello sir
so I gotta say [ __ ] I never have good
say can I help you can I help you out
Jay says the nerve of some people I try
to help people get in the way okay
[Music]
merrily appropriate time to kiss okay
help me out dad that my friends kinda
like inherit yes ma'am
shrapnel out physical asset my finger
take hurt for [ __ ] days like it still
[ __ ] hurts don't really know how to
get glass out thou I guess I wasn't
supposed to just like stay there that's
why just don't move the mugshot
hey I'm small and I guess I'll get rid
of that one yeah just gonna dig it out
that is valuable is that a buckshot one
over there what do I take out that belly
button now I'll just take this out sorry
[Music]
yeah you better not be allowed he
already got us into trouble silly that's
enough for now
yeah yeah I know that's my gun I don't
[ __ ] know laughter buddy
those guys shot I saw they saved us yeah
my remember Lois is still the enemy okay
that's all right
a cheese on the border
and how is that masked figure how much
money do I have them actually how do I
show a tip you know you did a lot kind
of but how much of it is his job how
much of it is that kebab from beyond you
know that's the part I don't really get
I didn't mean to endanger you walkers
were sent to her place are sent the
walkers was part of a group saw
themselves whispers they've learned to
live in herds among walkers move them
sometimes
why are you alone if you were part of
the group they disagreed or guess right
they attacked a community saw the
carnage okay thought [ __ ] is that an
onion oh it's an apple I was like dude
you can't [ __ ] any Italian both of you
we're [ __ ] that huh
si we don't take food from strangers
Horatio
let's see a name he is no one without
the mask
[ __ ] the [ __ ] that's dead James why
did you help us James for him not people
who attacked you children kids they took
to last year a common practice for them
they're at war up north
their entire community against another
it's why they take people to make them
fight train them use them
I guess all right you would join their
war that's great
see that's why I helped you Japanese is
that the first Japanese character I
think thank you wait
throwing distractor works just as well
and nobody gets hurt no it is yeah we'll
try it your way
try it your way it's like I can't write
like thank you it was difficult to send
the hurt in to save you I didn't want
them to die
that's a nice fire effects I mean I
think I have glass in my finger I don't
is that bad you know I swear try to dig
it out the other day yes do you just
hang around in the woods saving random
people yes after I can't I robbed me
though I wander first time alone never
did I lose my step belted everywhere
first against walkers and against each
other I hoped it would be better here no
you're wrong so I guess it it's okay to
think about where are you from Georgia
here or somewhere far away
Georgia long way from home it feels like
forever ago it was there's this best day
bang
I just missed a baby yeah well semester
where are you from
state the city just the same as that
question the city dad I ran a food truck
I helped oh yeah I got teeth I realize
that's all I gotta say
you've got a fever his wound will need
proper cleaning and medicine if you're
lucky enough to have any the school has
medicine but I don't think they'll share
it that's why those people attacked you
isn't it to get to that school mm-hmm
that's correct I'll destroy whatever
they find
bring more guns more fighters take
everyone inside they won't be able to
fight them off
hi I'm big Spang
you need medicine you have to go back
don't tell me what to do you know my dad
and I have to go back and warn them it's
the right thing to do noble of you
despite their treatment
I'll help you what is that hanging over
there doctor see if it is a few more
hours looks like it's like instruments
or some show like that
slave he's like I just got shot I'll
stay awake you don't have to thank you
sleep I'll keep watch
okay okay I will Hosea war my brother
not tonight
are you trying to remember so much about
me that's what I'm trying to question
to tall order games whereas dang you're
gonna achievement yeah this guy's so
ugly anyway
it's mask is he white yeah he's so hot I
can carry him here exhausted yeah that's
nice slaps no I've got him
what am I just did I carried him over
there yeah that'd be bad
yeah right now they're gonna shoot us up
okay you live out there alone right and
now you could stay with us I don't know
it's a masked man if that actually face
I was smell so [ __ ] bad not ready
okay
goodbye sir
I can't keep carrying you I'll be inside
soon rest now
[ __ ] yeah he's got a fever come on let's
get him inside
come on bro I can't
listen to you that Apple [ __ ] pansy I
still don't like you Louis stupid rats
and stupid okay buddy
this [ __ ] let me see she's like it's a
boy we got the shrapnel out of him we
it's a long story
as the couch it's a couch
you put him on the couch he's running a
fever body's trying to fight infection
for a little guy ritchie's I know we can
talk in the office Clem you just try to
rest okay
AJ listen to Ruby okay she'll look after
you come on what do we do when we're
scared when fear starts to get the upper
hand [ __ ] off to fear yes I'm so proud
of you I'm good now
I'm so [ __ ] proud of you
Clementine please we need to talk
what happened out in the woods I saw
they had you pinned tonight that's so
crazy
when I heard you call for help I didn't
even think I just let go over the arrow
I wasn't even sure if I'd hit her and
then Lois got shot six six inches over
we'd be digging another grave I really
thought you were dead clung it's just
everything is so [ __ ] right now you
know it's really good to see you again
it's good to see you too just wish Mitch
and the others felt the same these
people are gonna kiss between two ladies
we were wondering I mean I know you're
not like with her group she's horrible
she always has been
her dad was a racist [ __ ] and she
defended everything yeah a really good
episode season I guess she murdered
someone in our group gunned him down
during an argument Carly was her name
she refused to let Lily push her it was
right at the start I haven't seen really
sense but there's something else no you
let him write to us like that cuz I was
mad at you guys running into those two
in the woods
it proved we can't trust anybody
I'm not trying to be weird I just don't
want everyone in the world to know where
we are
well he said he was wearing I don't know
animal skins or something he wearing
Walker skin that's how he gets past
herds he can guide them to okay I
wouldn't have brought him here if I
thought he was a threat it's not that I
don't trust you I'm just worried about
the others and what they might do they
didn't even get a chance to mourn Brody
and Marlin before these child snatching
[ __ ] showed up and then you two come
back after we thought you were dead now
they're confused and no one knows how to
feel about AJ violet AJ is the least of
their worries
I know but everything is such a mess
they're scared and angry and they're
looking for someone to believe me I mean
they kicked you out how am I supposed to
make them change their minds about you
mmm it was decided five to three against
I know it feels like it shouldn't matter
but they were afraid of you both of you
you don't have to let me convince them
okay well her so cool James told me what
Lilly and Abel will do next
he said they'll get more people and guns
and come attack us take everyone here
how the hell would he know he's watched
them for a while they're at war with
another community they take people to
fight for them is that what happened to
mini and Sophie they turned them into
soldiers yeah it'll happen to us too if
we don't stop them and he didn't even
like killing walkers
look at this place it's a fortress that
schoolmaster with a little work we could
make this place really hard to attack do
you actually know how to do that yeah it
was part of a siege once in a town
called Richmond here let me show you
that's my favorite part when I choose
items traps to find the walls we've got
good strong walls yes
need to make them hard to climb over so
the Raiders have to come in through the
gates we used to keep barbed wire in the
greenhouse the courtyards pretty wide
open not a lot of cover we should flip
the picnic tables narrow down the
pathways through it so we'll know which
way they're coming at the very least is
protection and what's the last last dot
should we set traps in the Abin building
this is where we should make our stand
there's only one way in the front and
then there's the big central stairs oh
yeah if we rigged that path with traps
we can pull back here learning in our
attackers I like it and what about the
greenhouse well you guys don't use the
greenhouse anymore do you
no we used to then we lost someone up
there walkers over ran the place and
Marley wouldn't let us go back save some
we need to get that barbed wire so they
can't climb the walls
I'll go are you sure it's gonna be
swarming with walkers by now what the
hell's going on
that's bench they told me she was back
but I was like no way
violet wouldn't just go against what we
all decided that's like us but he's
still overweight his fevers already
going down claim he's gonna be okay
great we're just giving them our
medicine - Mitch those people who shot
Lewis they're bitching almost Stannis
Lewis so get out of here need Glen's
help like hell we do no way if you saw
their leaders boots neck you know that
use your head Mitch you saw AJ on your
way in if I was with the Raiders why
would they have heard him like no no no
maybe he shot one of their friends yeah
he [ __ ] up climbs going to the green
house to find barbed wire and anything
else she thinks we need for the fight
and you're going to help her no I'm not
yes you are it's too dangerous for her
to go by herself and you're good in a
fight but she's tough I can go to you
know to keep the peace [ __ ] bye since
when are you the one making a pass oh my
god [ __ ] these two or meet you at the
gate and you can head to the greenhouse
once I've explained the situation
okay
see you there no I guess you're doing
this boys I guess for telling this Louis
get the [ __ ] away from him the [ __ ]
the matter with that guy you got a lot
of nerve showing your face around here
Louis you got a lot of knife you uh yeah
yeah I stuttered the [ __ ] out of here he
puts a dirty you're making a [ __ ]
ground already get the [ __ ] out here
yeah hey hey yeah help dinner right
mommy's here okay don't how little it
was touch here again with his dirty
hands you're perfect
Louis is annoying
the greenhouse okay okay I didn't
realize how long it's been it's changed
oh she said they ain't budgin you gonna
stand there sulking all day you're gonna
do something useful well we need that
barbed wire there must be another way in
look at that yeah I thought look at the
Clocktower collectibles Gary found in
the world
alright don't mind if I tell you cool
toys out here what is this a pigeon yeah
daddy no good job or not too many in
these parts but they were more common
where I grew up I used to hunt him with
one man when I was little okay hey it's
so big that's when they died I like it
it'll look good on my wall okay no let
me say what the entrance is here spec
foggy glass looks clear time a language
condensation on the inside
condensation that's a big word for you
seriously shut up
it's you're a [ __ ] you want nothing
you're only here cuz we're desperate you
know so don't get comfy we survived
these Raiders you and I are gonna have
words let's survive first okay don't
mind if I do that window I bet we can
get in there good spot Mitch I mean
premier give me a boost
wait make her go first what the [ __ ]
that's an ugly thing to say that's he
mention your right
she shouldn't mind sticking her neck out
you first Mitch no see cuz the people
back home want me to survive this is
trip let's just get the stuff we need
okay just go I knew I'd have to go in
because it'd be boring it's like in the
game you just kind of stand there one
grabs you otherwise we'll come as soon
as you give the all-clear
I guess we'll know when the door opens
okay II know noe there's the guy over
there and then whenever I tell the whole
oppressed place it's like yeah
oh look see when this bets it up and
then if it's a I know this girl you made
sense these [ __ ] off SS Pat's I was
like wonder why I wouldn't let me press
the e button this is a really effective
what I know now that got way
he did okay so I think you can't they're
not bad you sent your face [ __ ]
we're not done hey not done here okay
well ginger Eastern prickly pear
Jerusalem artichoke false the home and
steal you're pretty proud of your wire
anything else that might be useful hey
chef yeah ate my ship what this was for
science you're [ __ ] now antibiotics
you bet any call things here yeah
where's all that noise mom are very nice
music pissed off
okay shovel could be a weapon you use it
to dig a grave
we were there when we dug the holes for
Marlon and Brody we had he was cups and
bowls told forever step it [ __ ]
yes Sally batch okay can I eat some more
[ __ ] mrs. clay this just looking at it
something yep
maybe useful trowel is good for prybar
yes definitely useful who's taking all
the [ __ ] that any of this yes dibs
and okay
[ __ ] red I think I saw it first
move this thing or pry it out been
shifted a what's in there oh my goodness
barbed wire a lot of it you as you keep
the Raiders from climbing our walls
hey you can use these for what you can
make bombs out of these bombs are you
serious
totally it's the kind of stuff I made
back home he used to blow [ __ ] up that's
why he's a troubled youth guilty I just
need some propane and something to
create a spark and we'll have ourselves
a nice little homemade explosive huh
that's safe I don't have I hate that and
it's not that
you seem very controlled you gotta have
the [ __ ] place
I remember right there's a science lab
through that door maybe there's propane
in there
propane and propane accessories thing
yeah what else I just don't do it I
guess I got a debt
all right watch out what do you think
yeah you can see what's inside this she
said that's fine see that you alright
oh you had a scare that's all that bad
what you know that's what she lured her
nurse to school she stayed she made the
wrong choice
she looks barely recognize her I guess
is this a sorry I just wish I could make
her look like she used to
one day we came out looking for food
walkers attacked us thought we could
fight him off but there were just
there's so many miss Martin told us to
run so we did
don't [ __ ] I want I heard that I feel
like chained that day she taught me how
to patch people up stitch in local
anesthetics painkillers fever reducers I
don't think I can
take care of her yeah would you I'm
sorry
let me just take down
I don't really [ __ ] her out I guess you
have no choice let's top that Zack
they find out that you'd yeah just
needed look you better hurry up [ __ ] we
got things to do you know we can get out
of here
Matt's friend I mean business pretty
good pretty good
Oh Tara huh oh wow that's cool
the headmaster on computers now let's
hope there's gas in it that's up oh [ __ ]
I had a few long chickens coffee fine
we got the propane now if we could just
find something to create a spark that
would be something internet circa
matches here beaker you find anything
I actually I don't know what this is I
think a baker says Baker right there
yeah that's over here look looks like
this dare you to drink it not the
million years wind it's good comeback
not lettuce Mitch is this useful
walking hey let's open there be one of
those that's an igniter we can use it to
create a spark it's the last thing we
need to blast those [ __ ] to
hell
whoa not until we bury miss Martin
Harrier why bother
it's a walker help me drag it out back
we can burn it no miss Martin's the
reason we're all alive and she deserves
a proper burial here next to the
greenhouse she loved that way the others
won't have to see her like this she's
like I really be dead for years there's
no spirit
it's the right thing to do for someone
you cared about huh thank you so much
it's not her it's a walker Mitscher I
can say fine whatever I'm not wasting my
energy on that thing
I'd say my so myself
that I can't see I had the same because
I'm you didn't kiss me get away from me
get the [ __ ] away from me okay
think it'll be enough Natalie it means
Lily and her people won't be able to
climb the walls they'll have to come
through the gates we can plan for that
straight into a fiery explosion of death
[ __ ] won't know what hit him I'm
gonna get you it's like crazy except
that you can't do that
[ __ ] brought you these I noticed his
shirt got messed up when you know where
did you get those [ __ ] outta here
attends back when he got here should be
about AJ sighs how's he doing better his
fevers down thank you for carrying him
in yeah no problem the greenhouse again
and bombs Mitch's idea I figured violet
says we'll start getting this place
ready in the morning
good they all seemed okay with letting
you stay for now anyway
while we get ready to fight - they
decided that before AJ got shot and
nearly killed they hope you feel badly
and safe mm-hmm
everyone else is okay with a stain what
about the [ __ ] that's fine
well he gets better and after that I
don't know Clementine
Clem hey kiddo how do you feel better
still hurts they're better that's how
Lewis why don't you like Louis I missed
you
Oh your friends again yeah just get some
sleep okay this is [ __ ] out lettuce
[ __ ] that you lose ya [ __ ] [ __ ] I
can't afford a view out I haven't
forgotten how you treated AJ or me I
haven't forgotten anything either
d8 it I never hated you I just didn't
know what else to do
forget it
I should go exactly get the [ __ ] out of
here
thank you a [ __ ] depressed hour right
here just puts a bat moving all around
yeah still mad I don't mind you he
helped carry me yeah I'm mad at him I'm
[ __ ] pissed he stopped think a cup of
that Bubba Jim not yet this is an
[ __ ] better a breath kiddo let's get
a look at the shirts Lewis brought you
then we'll sleep it's been a long day
yeah
James was nice but I don't like sleeping
on the ground
me neither
okay we got a couple choices here we got
what is that the disco I can't know what
the [ __ ] is that okay what do you got
roblox thing it's some thing just go
broccoli how you guys got broccoli it's
just go broccoli and his friend I wish
you could have seen this cartoon me too
you were a disc of broccoli okay yeah
time for sleep I can't sleep with a life
out in a second people can't sleep
without light they with the light on
just close your eyes you know like
that's why we eyelids like okay yeah I
got a bunch of fun goodies are they
weren't if it's a [ __ ] boar's head I
have a boar head okay I wonder how long
it'll last
that's my phone your stank's anything
else the girls around here another
achievement I'm [ __ ] going the same
looks scary oh it is
it's a flytrap it eats bugs a plant can
eat bugs yeah you bet you bet your
knickers that cat's got a slightly tight
and if it tries mmm that's right thanks
first ask questions later okay making a
mess every here
damn I assumed myself it's gonna snow
like crazy today so y'all [ __ ] better
get ready
these kids it hasn't even pests in two
weeks or angels aim at a man I won't be
nazuna saying [ __ ] my weakness is it's
like I can I [ __ ] help ya you know em
where are you left right that's fact
it's obviously just a dream
okay Jay hey Jay
okay this is obviously a dream first I
want you to start and I like wake her up
hello Jose Sinclair what's the [ __ ]
sky on all right
I thought there's a kid selling
you know was an excellent point
same one you used to have all the time
about what happened at the ranch I feel
safer like this not sleeping I want to
stay up forever
I probably good like 18 days if I tried
hard we're safe here AJ it doesn't feel
like it you used to think so
here let me help you back to bed no you
don't have to keep checking mm-hmm you
always say be tough so I am you say be
strong and I will all the time you're
the toughest boy I know probably the
toughest boy in the whole world you Wow
no one's as tough as me
I'm sorry you had to do all the hard
work showing them I'm good and smart
smart I'm gonna help you move so you
don't have to do everything where are
you going on Patrol patrol for danger I
had people monsters whatever they have
nightmares about this I bet what if you
stayed here instead if you go back to
sleep I'll stay awake and make sure no
more about dreams come you can't do that
you're not magic how do you know maybe I
have magic and never told you they don't
what is it could I maybe sleep in your
bed like I did when I was little yeah
come on up
I'm not scared just tired to make sense
to me
think you need that I'm gonna [ __ ]
show that insane
a j-1 you're still little yeah yes Dylan
my dad lost his phone I will say that
much
you're ready to work today kiddo
bad dreams always make me more tired me
too better in your bed Ferger where this
kid came from honestly those extreme to
yourself yeah actually could you check
on everyone like 10 years
I should go board up the back hallway
since Louis isn't gonna do it let me go
give Louis a piece of my [ __ ] mind
[ __ ] suck in a few weeks days or
hours the Raiders will be here burn down
our place and steal or kill us
yes Raiders aren't gonna burn anything
or steal anybody we'll stop it you sound
like Marlin I mean not about fighting
but he was trying to cheer us all up for
years I sat around making stupid jokes
playing stupid games my responsibility
all the tough calls yeah you're pretty
badly yourself and then when you tried
to tell us what he was really like and
AJ shot him I blamed you
mm-hmm yeah you do a lot of bad things
it's not day one [ __ ] I didn't want to
hurt you too I just I was
anything that practice [ __ ] Lee
Lewis
yeah [ __ ] bro
[ __ ] bro anyhow Louis disgust myself
buses around here that you in here yeah
Matt's up just gotta see if the bomb
will go off this little thing will kill
anybody just gotta see if it'll like
better the whole plan rests on that
little thing if they get in I'll need
you to set the bomb off while I distract
them expect the unexpected
yeah something like that I read that I'm
one of those stupid inspirational
posters school needs to have them
everywhere
so those things went to [ __ ] I tore them
all down could you my hands I'm [ __ ]
up for messing with it all day
that [ __ ] [ __ ] doesn't work [ __ ] I'm
sure you'll get it keep trying [ __ ] out
I'll figure it out
just need more time alone time to think
thanks though
but you know it's too bad that's better
than a person that's okay Rosie that
piece I thought I eats a lot of [ __ ]
Marlins he's kind of a dick I don't
really spin on it yeah [ __ ] yeah that's
right Brody's I hope it's beautiful
where you are Brody Brody again
miss Martin thanks for protecting
everyone okay there anything else I need
to do not really sure where the [ __ ] the
other people are they're fine Outsiders
only I get stinky out here
well it's looking scary over here
fine
there's someone by that dork scary
oh yeah if it were up there we go there
we go do you think Sophie and Minnie my
beautiful when they kiss her maybe maybe
that's totally different than that role
how so
you don't whoa oh right
shaking with violence alright okay you
know a total [ __ ] mess they're ready
for this violet told us to work on the
traps together but a similar you're dumb
doesn't mean you have to scream at each
other stay out of this I have an idea
for duffle bags with Rick's we drop them
on the Raiders to take out one Raider at
most it's completely stupid stupid we
should use this brick trap it sounds
more practical it's practical too it's
exactly the kind of thing a child has no
idea what he's up against
[ __ ] holy [ __ ] you in a restaurant K
yeah well I'll kill each other before
the Raiders even get a [ __ ] chance
what we need is something to break the
tension
dude [ __ ] off sulking in the corner
isn't gonna help us fight off the
Raiders or turn that frown upside down
you get more annoying every day
regardless I've come up with a plan to
make everybody feel better and that plan
is a game I mean if you want to go ask
Ruby to come play oh you use cards and
truth or dare you do in this version
everyone draws highest cards to pass
that's pretty good game actually I hit
the peck let's see truth marry [ __ ] kill
all right fine Mary flip flip flip oh my
god I would
James sounds mysterious
funny you pronounced horrifying
differently than I do
didn't you say he was sorry
I was just imagining her glare while
propositions saying I got the highest
card or I win definitely a dare okay do
your worst
you have to ask Ruby for a kiss
seriously the most legitimate of dares
do you get [ __ ] like refuse to play
this game I got it
we've been pretty hard on poor sim here
teasing him about sweet Ruby seems only
fair we mercilessly tease someone else
about unrequited okay oh my god yeah
definitely got feelings for someone oh
my god I gotta take my [ __ ] socks off
but something you've never told anyone
because you were afraid they'd make fun
of you you're so [ __ ] dumb you should
be ashamed of yourself
they definitely burn part of your brain
that way yeah I don't it's great there's
a movie there's a new [ __ ] today other
than it's like hanging around
it's okay second deck believe me the
world before this one was pretty shitty
and that feels like a good place to call
it we should finish up our work anyway
it's getting dark you're on Lookout yep
clementines got it after me okay no get
the [ __ ] out of here okay this guy let's
see here
hey hey you maybe want to help me with
the brick trap yeah I got some ideas
cool I'm sure they'll help sorry I
punched you it's okay
it's a pretty good punch I'm headed to
the bell tower on the back before bed
you need help chop it into firewood I
need a second person okay I'm done with
my life is Lewis is that dumb person
yep
[Music]
[Music]
between church and Bible study
up a nice dinner party this [ __ ] fall
there that gonna fall it's gonna [ __ ]
fall not very nice
barbed wire traps weapons he made it
happen they couldn't have done it
without you I'm straight
you got Lookout duty tonight right me AJ
do you have get out first
oh my yeah it's happening was it's
happening girls oh I tell you no yeah
where you go or Chacho buckle up but
your seatbelts in tiny bounce button up
those shirts oh my got that moon's out
beautiful yeah
just to get away for a while yeah yeah I
got it
you know he came back for medicine for
AJ but after that you could have just
left avoided all the [ __ ] with the
Raiders
you gotta stay a little bit I mean have
a for dead thing because why would I go
anywhere else if you're here oh my god
I'm glad oh when I got her I wasn't was
popped at her [ __ ] head that cuz it
was so cool let's make some come over
here you can sit down about that strong
sound if I remember right everyone's
born under a special sign right it
determines your personality that's
astrology not astronomy whatever let's
just make up our own rules science what
it says about you sound like anyone
remembers the old way okay let's do it
now there's definitely there's like big
blinking and older I think there's a
fashion
I said needs a personality right pretty
good with other people always moving
tons of energy
Louis the energy one is easy good with
people not so much that's AJ wherever I
look there he is taking up all my
attention and I love it
it's getting better around other people
you're doing good thank you
no no right there my head
okay luckily it tells you which one I go
to next
smart clean vicious dependable that's
yeah that's a crap from anyone get [ __ ]
done sounds just like you I like that
yeah
oh my god the last ones out there give
me a starboard no no what a star Perez
so I don't really like drawing stuff
that's not real
you know you know the fact I got now
that again
here
all these [ __ ] stars coming out
nowhere for me it could go anywhere it
wanted to up and death end up and never
come back
Oh south east west doesn't matter I wish
it was me maybe you will learn to fly
together someday oh my god sorry I
didn't mean to just talk so much oh my
god it's just I've watched people leave
before family friends Yeah right gob a
bang you did he'll be here favorite oh
man I can't imagine roll like my god oh
my god it sounds much dumber when I say
it out loud I think oh my god
oh my god holy Toledo oh my god Oh
the crews around here where the [ __ ] I
think we leave the property ready that's
got that bang yeah
and loves laughing
that is insane today you won't say that
the Raiders that guy he's gonna be with
him yeah your bad dreams they're all
about him aren't they yeah
[ __ ] really hate that [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] that was so funny
oh my god Wow really funny oh my
goodness about something else
count the monsters you see three for AJ
it's okay if Abel frightens you you know
how to control that there's ten monsters
out there that was insane but when he
comes here I call dibs okay I'm the one
that kills him okay
okay really yes I can't promise you how
things are gonna go but if it's possible
you get first shot at him Wow
what you thought I'd say no yeah I'm
grown-up now no you aren't but I'm close
Klim I see something not a walker here
you look too
then
you tell me I'll [ __ ] see that that's
not a walker
good job EJ come on we have to tell the
others can't wait go back
we're doing this they finally show up
yeah see okay we're ready
you've got at least four more people all
carrying guns and carts probably to
carry people away no [ __ ] I can't
believe they're really here if they get
inside be surprised she's like one
promise they manage to get in we fall
back to the admin building exactly right
into our traps they're in for a rude
[ __ ] surprise those duffel bags will
break bones easy so any final words of
wisdom kick some ass [ __ ]
thanks seven one after all well sort of
what happens
oh my leave him leave him where he's
done he punch you're just slowing him
down
Oh Go Go
I'll be all right okay get out of here
go get that ball back okay this barson
port right here
okay I gotta tap this and everybody
someone's tapping the hold that's all
great
well you got a horse is everything okay
just try not to move or make noise
we're gonna get this badge [ __ ] you
solve this
yes they took this seriously right out
let's get this [ __ ] I'm not gonna miss
a single trigger you won't get the
chance
where's our new recruit shut the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] not yours
a shudder search the yard
if Clementine moves shooter
we'll find them Clementine and then
we'll take them okay do that often
where's our new recruit they're not
yours search the yard
I say if Clementine moves shooter why
she's apprised we'll find them
Clementine and then we'll take them
Angie I don't think you want to kill me
just like you didn't want to in the
woods [ __ ] do it can you
you've changed I grew up I can see that
God you are just like him we would have
been heartbroken knowing he taught you
all the wrong things that the sweet
little girl he protected turned out like
this he taught me how to survive how to
kill yeah some job he did still died
Clementine
get out if you won't help me find the
others I'll find someone who will we
recruited from this school before Minny
wanted to come along tonight to tell you
how well she's adjusted to her life how
happy she is she said she had a
girlfriend back here friends she missed
one guy who could always make her laugh
no matter what [ __ ] where are they
let me take you to them I can't I just
please
yeah yeah [ __ ] rocket sit that this
[ __ ] thanks to the EMS missing you are
dumb I said an ass
Bock and arrow to the knee
mmm where's the brick trap
oh he's [ __ ] dead
oh yeah oh [ __ ] is that one old side is
like [ __ ] done dudes
okay go fire baby tell him it's time you
learned
please get this
oh he's like on the guys talking oh yeah
he got him there you go this guy's not
down at your hot yes stamp it backs
should be easy
yes their pet batch get it over with
you won't kill me I know you won't
why like family once he won't hurt
family that's God I got him I got him
buzz oh yeah we got him
already got him right gun all right
[ __ ]
that guy is like we're really losing it
apart every single forward buys [ __ ]
she's gonna get out of here hey can I
have one
[Music]
alright I like that concept [ __ ]
okay
that's
[ __ ]
I thought that now
set I never see that one
I got me and it's really bad at that
okay let's x8 focus now
[ __ ] it's like [ __ ] stuttering
that yeah okay
why
set
I don't know you can [ __ ] walk at the
same time
and I got bets we got him that's it so
far what's that right I did have one
that I make has met rep he's kind of a
dick where's Louis is he dad now the
kiss
trying to this arrows huh 10 yeah you
sound like Mitch getting brazen murder
do not accuse I answer back it's gonna
get wait what happened to that guy clam
what was it soon alarm I I'm sorry for
trusting her yeah that's a [ __ ] idiot
see [ __ ] ass and yourself damn it I
know we're gonna look after them if we
knew where to look I'd smash down their
walls myself but we don't I know it's us
James
well we've got someone who does
ah yes we're gonna [ __ ] this guy up babe
we're gonna [ __ ] this guy yeah oh yeah
hey Zeiss fix I thought he had like a
[ __ ] like lighthouse stuck in it
how's that well that's a great episode
these are watching y'all exciting I'm
very excited with new one after I
[ __ ] love kind of back playing them
like back dating I mean because now I
get this play next
okay so yeah that's six more people to
hold till they get this gun yeah it's
got thirty four percent one percent
didn't intervene when they G insisted
thank you I just had said nothing okay
he told Bob to shoot Lily and got Lewis
shot
perfect so her 15 that's fine you at 93%
spare the Walker honoring James Ross
okay and 58 from time stargazing ya know
like Louis 50% of them are scooty yeah
56 okay okay where do you good very good
well that should be it oh the change
feeling trusted you James the tree WETA
let him keep the Apple Juno tenant when
he said he originated from Georgia
I can't tennis left her feeling grateful
shocked today it was cute blah consoled
about the nurse it's just dad she's know
raised me said a little irritated yeah
somebody good cuz he end up that again
we allowed him to be kidnapped looked in
discarded can't stand that guy
capture we got them again unimpressed
when did we help her to stand oh except
I hope the stand just a fad vanish full
okay only [ __ ] laughter they're ashamed
he should be ashamed save the school
Omar kidnapped Rosie good Willie I said
yeah the sims kidnapped oh yeah three
okay I guess that's that thanks for
watching y'all thank you and see y'all
next episode episode three